you stopped doing that tonight I needed
just one strand of your hair let me
explain something my hair is not to be
meddled with your father's here what's
this that's your brother Loki you're
gonna need that oh you are good all
right well I'll be off now um if it's
all the same to you I'm gonna use my
feet to walk outside instead of suddenly
just being out sights making me feel
rather queasy
thank you for your help I sense a great
change in your future Thor change you
can neither control nor avoid and you
have chosen many paths in your life but
now only one remains destiny has dire
plans for you my friend
it's incredibly depressing yeah I know
sorry I didn't mean exam really by day
yeah okay well listen good luck with
that and don't forget your umbrella who
can't you just magic it over to me can't
do that
[Applause]
see that's bad luck guess that's what
you have to talking about it's exactly
what I was talking about good luck nice
guy
it took you long enough
I had to pick up the key
[Music]
well
executioner hey stop it hold on right
there easy does it
Hoss wait a minute you know we're Kevin
and Lou's offices are now oh thanks man
go ahead proceed hey everybody is
Charlie hopefully you guys have had a
chance to see thor ragnarok by now I got
a couple requests to do videos for some
of the funnier deleted scenes there's a
lot more than this but these are
probably two of the best ones that I
haven't talked about before and the
yondu one was actually a big secret up
until recently so if you're finding me
for the first time I'm doing an Infinity
Gauntlet replica giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video probably
the two funniest moments during these
are when Thor jokes to Doctor Strange
can't you just magic my hammer over here
because it's still the umbrella and he
goes I think you know this wizard can't
do that just telling him yeah there's no
way that I'm worthy enough to lift that
hammer jokingly admitting to the fact
that he used to be just like Tony Stark
like maybe they'll be worthy someday but
yeah there's no way like they're just
not that kind of person they're not like
Captain America they can't make Thor's
hammer budge
[Music]
so you have to imagine dr. strange
trying to lift Thor's hammer in that age
of Ultron scene like nope not gonna
happen they've been a lot of theories
too he could probably lift the
enchantment on it he is that powerful so
the movie is breaking canon technically
Doctor Strange could lift it but he
would have to lift the enchantment
that's on at first but there's actually
a couple more complicated explainers for
wide Thor's hammer has that enchantment
on it and how it manipulates gravitons
to prevent other people from lifting it
when it senses they're not worthy
so the MCU version of the hammer is a
little bit different from the comic book
version of the hammer the comic book
version is actually alive it can see
into your soul when it senses someone
who is unworthy tries to lift it it just
manipulates the graviton field around it
making its own relative mass that much
greater so imagine the unworthy Tony
Stark using all of his technology his
gauntlets trying to lift the hammer in
the hammer increasing its mass to match
the force with which he's lifting it so
even if Tony Stark had the Hulkbuster it
had all this crazy force to lift the
hammer the hammer itself would just
increase its own relative weight so that
it would look like he couldn't lift it
most of you have probably suspected
correctly the Captain America actually
kind of let go
authority me like he tried to make it
budge and then sort of gave up halfway
through like he could have probably
lifted it in that moment had he
committed to it the deleted yondu scene
is just something that's a little bit
funnier he was never intended to be a
part of thor ragnarok
the way James Gunn explained it is that
they were filming this Asgard scene in a
studio in Atlanta where they filmed most
of their Marvel movies in Michael Rooker
was there in full makeup to shoot more
footage for guardians mission breakout
which is a Disneyland attraction based
on guardians of the galaxy Michael
Rooker wanted to check the set out and
just goof around a little bit in Taika
Waititi the director was like yeah sure
let's go around like we have a little
bit of time so Michael Rooker was
already in full makeup doing something
else for Marvel and they just walked on
to the thor ragnarok stage while they
were doing this but as you probably
detected when he says he's looking for
Kevin and Liu's office
he's talking about Kevin Feige and Lou
Esposito Lou Esposito is like the
producer for most of these big Marvel
movies one of the guys that helps Kevin
Feige keep Marvel Studios on track and
on budget
let me know in the comments though
what's your favorite part of this and
for those of you asking about Thor's new
weapon is it gonna be the same as
mjölnir because it was enchanted only
worthy people could lift it the only way
that his new Stormbreaker
axe would be like that is if somebody
enchanted it again some magic is too
powerful to sustain so we imbue objects
with it allowing them to take the strain
we cannot in Thor doesn't know how to
cast enchantments so either Doctor
Strange or Loki or someone else who knew
magic would have to do that like if the
king of the dwarves added some special
properties to it like it would seem kind
of lame if it was just a regular axe so
I have a feeling that it will have some
of the special properties of Mjolnir but
it won't be exactly the same there's a
bunch of other videos that I'm working
on right now but if you guys didn't know
there is a big-budget Witcher TV series
that's coming that's gonna be based on
the novel so I'll do a video for that
next explaining where it's at they just
finished the pilot so really cool stuff
coming congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Darth impulse please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round on
this video I'll just name a winner when
I post new Marvel click here for that
new infinity war promo they just
released and click here to learn more
about Thor's new weapon thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]